surf and turf tostada Bice you guys got
to give this a try it's so easy to make
it's absolutely delicious we start by
punching out mini tostadas from our corn
tortillas and jump into our prep work
thinly sliced red onions next prep your
guacamole by mashing avocados lemon
juice and salt in a Ziploc bag we fry
our mini to sadas at 325 and cook our
pre-marinated carnea Sada and slice
thinly last step is to marinate our
shrimp with olive oil and any seasoning
mix you like I'm using a Pia seasoning
we had our guacamole and a Ziploc bag
and there's a reason for that we're
going to use this to pipe the guacamole
onto each individual tost each tost gets
guacamole surf or turf onions CA cheese
and to make it look pretty we garnish
with cilantro and now it's time to enjoy